this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
be intentional about your character you
can have money and a career you are the
hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey show where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money I am
Ramsey a personality Rachel Cruz hosting
today with Dr John deloney and it's a
free call anywhere in the country at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so we'll talk about your your
marriage your money your life your
relationships anything and everything
just give us a call up first is Doug
from Boise hey Doug welcome to the show
hi Rachel thank you for taking my call
today how are you we're doing well
thanks so much how can we help
so I think I kind of have a bit of an
issue on baby step two I feel like I'm
just on a like a debt treadmill where
the process is just never ending and it
seems like no matter what I do to get
out of it I always kind of just slump
right back into it and I think it might
be something psychological that I just
can't quite figure out and I was curious
to see if you'd be able to help me with
that yeah absolutely okay so give me a
little bit of background like how much
debt how much did you have left what's
been what's been your journey what's
caused you to go back in
I mean it's always just a really small
amount of of credit card debt I don't
have any student loans I don't have any
car payments or anything like that and
every once in a while I'll find myself
getting into a a hole of about three to
four thousand dollars in credit cards
and I sit there and tell myself you got
to be kidding me I can't keep doing this
you know if if I want to make it through
this and make it through the baby steps
I think this is kind of just where I'm
having my issues what's causing you to
swipe the credit cards is it emergencies
that happen is it impulse purchases
what's the thing that's driving that
three to four thousand and credit card
debt constantly
I think it might be impulses and things
that I tell myself could be emergencies
that that aren't emergencies if I go out
and I'm doing something and you know
buying something that I shouldn't we're
saying hey there's these new shoes
they're really cool I need those
so I just think it's a lot of impulses
and a lot of things like that
um that's that's causing that so I I
want you to would you be willing to try
something new
of course okay
um two things I want you to try new one
I want you to look at this not as you're
a loser and a failure and an idiot but I
want you to look at this as an
environmental issue okay
is that cool yeah because you're in a
system now that you've created for
yourself you've just created a loop for
yourself where you do this thing and
then you feel like crap about it and
then you White Knuckle your way through
it for a minute and then
you feel a little bit better and then
you go do it again and the whole Loop
starts over again right
you're just like on one of these like
kids like train tracks so
let's stop beating up on Doug number one
number two change your environment get
rid of all of your cards
cancel Amazon Prime make it almost
freaking impossible for you to do this
so for me I am a raging sugar addict
comically so like my friends make fun of
me it's it's ridiculous my kids make fun
of it it's like dummy it's gross stuff
it's not even good yes it's not even
like a Snickers it's like or like an
apple pie yes it's gross it's it's like
a main line how like yes yes I may have
snorted sugar before so listen so listen
I have to have a home that doesn't have
any of that in it and my wife like when
I'm out of town my wife and kids they
have like they go get ice cream and it's
like it's it's an enjoyable time for
them I had to create an environment
where I don't even have access to it
which then gave me time to
let that addiction simmer and stop and
then I can re-enter the world does that
make sense
yeah that makes a lot of sense actually
and what I would tell you is until
you're ready to change the environment
you're not ready to stop spending and to
truly get out of debt and those are the
two like those first two things Doug
like what John is saying is spot on and
then even when you're out of it and
you're kind of in a in a better habit of
okay I'm not going into debt for the
stuff because I don't have the ability
to I have no I have no credit cards I'm
not beating myself up but then go into
the practice because even when you
become healthier with money I think
still asking the question why am I
wanting to spend this money that's right
what is it is it because it's going to
make me feel good in the moment because
I'm sad or I'm depressed or I'm
discouraged or I'm bored or is it
because I feel bad about myself and this
thing's gonna make me feel better
because I'll get compliments from it
like like find that root too because
again buying stuff is is not the issue
it's why you're doing it is kind of that
underneath Doug is what John's kind of
getting at as well so and I I have found
working with at people who struggle with
the ditch and
you I ca let me just talk about myself I
can't make that change in that
environment yeah I yeah I can't be
surrounded by bags of marshmallows and
and gummy candies as I'm Shoveling them
in going I wonder why I'm doing that
yeah I need to have a clear slate so
then when I feel the impulse I can then
stop and say
what am I hiding from here what is my
body trying to protect me from right and
that's the same with alcohol and
pornography all the things right
spending here I love that clear the deck
and then begin to feel your body and
begin to ask why am I leaning into this
why am I trying to cover something up
what is it I'm trying to cover up yeah
and and just the in the spending in
general in life in our country today is
so normal you know consumerism is like
at an all-time high and so what are the
things even if you're even if you're
someone listening and you're not dug
you're like oh I'm not going deep in
credit card debt there are still things
that I even put in place as a natural
spender I know myself
and even on baby step seven even though
we may even have it in the budget I
still feel convicted at times of like
why am I really do it like what is why
am I spending this and so I unsubscribe
from emails all the time I'll go back
through because sugar is your thing
clothes are mine I love shopping it's
just my thing but I'll go through and
I'm like okay I'm gonna unsubscribe from
all these emails because every time
there's a sale anytime there's anything
it pops up in my Gmail account and I'm
like oh my gosh there it is I never
would have known that existed on
Instagram I unfollow people not because
they're terrible and evil but for me I'm
like everything that she posts I want
and I'm like you know what just get just
just it's just a click away it's just a
click away and then I never save
passwords I never try to save my debit
card information website and me too I
have to re-login starts from scratch
everything you're like I gotta go find
the car I got it and it gives this
friction in our purchasing as well which
I think is really I think it's huge
again whether you're like Doug and
you're like oh my gosh I just seem to
keep going into it but even if you're
not I think it's just a good practice to
slow down and ask the questions okay
what why why why am I needing this why
do I feel like I want to buy it and
you've just done something important the
companies don't make things convenient
because they're your friend they make it
convenient because you're more likely
just to stumble in and hit by now bye
now by now so again I'm the same as you
I have to set with the Fourth of July
thing came through in this like the 24
hour flash sale and I was with some a
buddy in the middle of nowhere and he's
like oh I got to get online
it was so annoying having to re-log in
and learn a new thing and punch it but I
have to set those breaks for myself
otherwise I'm just buying this bag and
buying this thing and I need this new
whatever and it yeah it just gets out of
control for me yeah it's are you more
natural saver spender oh my gosh spender
oh
why did I ask that that was a moment
where uh directly imposit actually
helped me because I would go to the bank
and cash my check and it would never
make it home so actually by my company
sending my check directly to the bank
they take me out of the equation it
actually helps me out yeah oh so good so
good all right spinning absolutely again
free call anywhere in the country AAA
825-5225 here to talk about your life
and your money this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by Oracle including Ramsey
Solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory HR planning budgeting and more
All in One dashboard go to netsuite.com
Ramsay right now to get their free white
paper jump start your CFO career
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting today with Dr John
deloney all right Justin is up next in
Denver hey Justin welcome to the show
hi Rachel hi John uh read both of your
books loved them oh thanks so much well
thanks for calling yep how can we help
my wife and I
to we paid off forty thousand dollars in
the last five months wow congratulations
thank you we were celebrating our four
year anniversary next week and
um just this morning my wife told me
that her father
uh had uh told us that he was forgiving
uh the seven thousand dollars balance of
a ten thousand dollar family loan
um that they loaned us prior to our
marriage
um that's generous and uh yeah they live
close by and they come over often and I
fear that in the future once they
forgive this debt if I
um continue on they will uh I I just
fear facing them
do you fear facing them like ego wise or
is this loan forgiveness come with
strings federal government I like
no my my wife says and swears up and
down that they are not like that and I
believe her okay
um and she's she's on board with me she
hates owing anybody any money this is
our last debt before we move on to uh
maybe step three and
um and I I just can't bring myself to
feel right about the Forgiveness why not
well the original family alone was for
her to pay for her lawyer fees
um her ex-husband and her daughter
um per the divorce agreement or whatever
we're supposed to stay in the same
county as her husband
um for a visitation or whatever and she
wanted to move in with me prior to us
getting married and
um that created
um a Family Law Court case
um which she needed a lawyer for so from
my perspective I saw her appearance as
taking a bet on me the winter biological
father would not do that they bet on our
relationship it's been a very Rocky
marriage just because of the ends of the
spectrum that both of us fall on she's a
mental health counselor a retired army
um so they're betting on our marriage
from my point of view and it just pains
me to have this debt forgiven
um Let me let me reframe this let me
reframe this I don't think anybody's
betting on anybody sounds like a mom and
dad who love their daughter
and it sounds like a mom and dad who
loved their daughter and trust you
there's nobody's gambling on anything
here
and so
in your marriage by the way isn't been
Rocky because you're in the Army and
she's a mental health counselor it's
because it's just been Rocky makes them
different choices
no to me like don't don't over dramatize
this it sounds a lot like you don't like
the ego of this it's I mean this is
about your ego
that's what it sounds like
and if I'm you I would walk over to his
house or drive over there and I'd knock
on his door and I'd stick my hand out
and shake his hand if not hug him and
say thank you
and then when you are on more secure
Financial footing and you feel compelled
to pay the seven thousand bucks back and
you're in a position to do so then go do
it at that point and let some space
happen between there or if suddenly he's
holding this over your head and
weaponizing it then go take out a loan
at a credit union and give him his money
back
but I this sounds a lot like ego man and
this isn't the moment for ego this is a
moment to say thank you I'm grateful
but you've created a conflict like
they're betting on this and I I'm dude
just say thank you man
and then be about making your marriage
Stronger Yeah and Justin do you is there
patterns with your relationship with
them that's causing you to to get here
because at this point I feel like you
said that it's been a pretty good
relationship with them and you haven't
seen anything but have you deep down is
there something that you're like oh God
they've made that comment that comment
that comment that's helped you write
this story or is it just it just feels
so I mean you just kind of can't believe
oh my gosh that this debt he's gonna
just forgive it and then you kind of
start rattling around in your in your
head with it
not really sure what's going on with
that I I know that you know over the
last nine ten months now I've I've had a
lot of shame in my life
um
uh you know I've I've I quit drinking 10
months ago and uh
um so there's a lot of shame
I destroyed some relationships and uh
you know the worst one was uh trust with
my wife and I'm trying to rebuild those
relationships and my life it seems like
my life is cool isn't that on me I'm
getting the help that I need excellent
um
let me tell you something that's
counterintuitive to the space you're in
the space you're in especially with your
training is that you are going to grab
control
I'm going to quote unquote solve this I
screwed something up fix it right that's
the mentality and that there is some
truth to that you've got to do right by
your wife you've got to repair that
relationship and that comes with doing
different things
but globally speaking grabbing the wheel
tighter
is not going to stop the spin of this
thing
it's releasing that
and what that looks like is going to
somebody's house and saying thank you
the word that nobody likes to use is
vulnerability and that's the only path
forward for you and vulnerability for
for a veteran is counterintuitive I'm
rolling you could hurt me right now
and I'm gonna go anyway
because you're my wife because you're my
in-laws you're my family now
and I'm going to trust that you won't
hurt me and I'm going to say thank you
I'm gonna go on to being a good man is
that fair
yes I want you to very much but listen
brother I want you to look at this not
as like I told the previous caller this
isn't a some kind of moral failure
this is a set of skills you don't have
and you got to learn some new skills and
you got to practice them is that cool
yes so practice accepting help practice
think thank you and then and then
practice saying I'm sorry how can we
make this right
okay is that cool
yes go make your marriage good man
you're worth that it's good we're
testing appreciate you man and that's a
lot of Courage it's a bold calling yeah
yeah it's a brave guy I really
appreciate you calling Justin but and
it's a there's a level in all of us
right in our lives whether it's within
our marriage within our money
uh anything new even accepting a gift
right
um all of it to your point I'm like when
you don't have the practice and the
skills it's it is so uncomfortable and
it is so scary But continuing to step
into it and continuing to take a step it
takes courage a different level of
Courage than I feel like our world talks
about oh well there's it's it's
relational courage which is like like if
if Suzanne fires me she takes my job
from me right but my identities with my
wife and kids whatever
if I lose that then I've gotta that's
that's a long road right I don't know
who I am I'm untethered to everything
right and so there's something
incredibly Courageous about leaning into
someone that you love and care about who
is part of you which is your wife your
husband your spouse your kids and saying
I'm sorry
thank you how do I do this right like we
just don't have we don't have a culture
that just says I'm sorry how do I make
this right we have one that says fix it
and when we fix it we try to grab
control of it yes and sometimes you
gotta do the opposite of what you're
what your training is yeah which is so
scary and that's the vulnerable piece
when you're not used to that and it's
like okay I really am I'm gonna I'm
gonna let go of the wheel in a sense
um and other other people who have spent
their whole lives with their hands off
the wheel equally courageous you've got
to grab the wheel like you've got to
take some control here right and and so
some people are listening going like
okay I should look like you got to know
you and everybody's situation is
different it's it's doing the if you
here's the thing look at the pattern of
behavior in your life
look back and say is this working this
is your four and my marriage is still a
mess me getting angry every time this or
me going to watch Netflix every time or
grabbing another drink every time that's
not working let's try something else do
the courageous thing that makes your
body uncomfortable because that usually
is the right thing yeah trying something
the next hard thing that's so good well
thanks again Justin for calling it's
awesome this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more verse
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
Rachel Cruz with Dr John deloney
and obviously there's things set on the
show that people don't agree with and
that are controversial and how you live
life and we kind of talk about common
sense and we could sit here and talk
about the color of the sky and the
leaves and we would be like
that's not true that's yours that's not
true that's your truth you got a liberal
garbage oh my gosh the sky is orange
idiot oh so yeah so the basis if you're
new to this show I mean honestly like
the most foundational principles it's
common sense it's biblical and it's
after 30 years of doing that we're like
okay here's what works and And in
regards to money and then obviously over
the past couple years bringing in people
like John's talk about mental health and
other spaces but still applying that
same logic of like okay what is you know
gods and Grandma's ways it's kind of the
tagline of doing life and and that's
worked
so one of the things that we talk about
a lot that we just get or I do I get
crap for all the time is about combining
your accounts after you're married when
you get married you should have one bank
account with your spouse
it's literally the dumbest thing I've
ever heard right and you you sound like
I mean I was trying to be all of social
media it is like like I mean and
the credit score I can talk about manual
underwrite I can talk about all these
things but this one it just touches a
nerve okay so I didn't know this was a
thing until I joined this team like
right so when I came to hang out here
and I think it was me and you were
hanging out
people will create other humans
together and they will not share an
account
yet your genetics are shared
we will make a person together but I'm
not letting you have my not my fun money
like we literally have created somebody
or something that could destroy Humanity
but you are not touching my paycheck
that's mine oh man but the advice is out
there so I saw this on uh well I
shouldn't say I saw it on Tick Tock but
I don't have Tick Tock but someone
shares your child is a huge Tick Tock
fan that's the thing that's what it is
James the producer loves Tick Tock no
okay so this is Kevin O'Leary Shark Tank
and here's his advice
I tell women today do not merge your
account with your husbands ever in your
whole life he will respect you for
having your own money let him have his
and set up a third account when you
merge your dollars together there's no
reason you have to give up your
financial identity when you marry
wow no reason to give up your financial
identity
[Laughter]
I don't even have
[Music]
okay because here's okay I don't even
know what to say well I have so many
places I want to start okay number one
let's let's just do this real life
Rachel uh we were we're out to dinner
with two couples that we know and both
women work and so that right they're a
dual income family
and both of them both of the guys what
well sorry one of the girls she pulled
back from work right she's like I'm
gonna I'm pulling back uh so she's she's
home with the kids and they have school
age kids and she's just home and he's
kind of like oh and she says I feel like
I'm missing something for the
contributing to the household because we
hear that a lot all the time
contributing to the household and he's
kind of giving her a hard time because
he's like you have a great brain like
you could use the brain and make money
you know this whole thing and so there
is this this position when you are
married and a wife and a husband and
you're there and you're talking about
money uh lots of different perspectives
right that you can go into but when it
comes to just sharing the account like
just the just like we're just gonna go
Baseline that all of your money goes
into one account right
why would you not
except for if there's an if there's an
abusive situation if there's a situation
divorce on the horizon and you know like
yeah or you've got to create a pocket
for safety right yes yes
um but for majority of couples out there
functioning just in marriage and they're
just living their lives so what I take
from that call is this
I want to get married to somebody I want
to do I want to join lives together
but I want to stay completely and
totally autonomous and still be quote
unquote just me
and then I'm going to be me you be you
and then we'll do this together thing on
the side or maybe we'll do it in the
middle but I'll be me on the side and
you on the side and so I'm going to keep
my loan identity here you keep your loan
identity here yep and what that is
called is a corporation that's a
business Arrangement yes I'm gonna go to
my house you go to your house you go to
your side of the bed and then we'll do
this job together and that's not
marriage no and and it's more I mean
back to the other call we had on the
last segment there's a vulnerability to
say I'm going to give everything to you
yes and we're going to go in this
marriage together and we are going to be
one in every aspect so let me push back
on this in again yeah clearly a super
successful Financial Financial person
I I I have never heard a man say you
know what I would really respect my wife
if she were less connected with me and
more independent and you don't hear that
kind of language you hear the opposite I
feel completely and totally alone in a
bed I share with my partner yes I feel
completely and totally alone at dinner
with my wife and kids or my husband and
kids because we are not you're not
unified in what we're doing in our lives
like the connection point of where we
are as a state relationally yes should
say something exactly that what we're
doing is a world with Merit is it's not
working yeah so like so let's just do
the opposite of what the world's doing
AKA unite but no and so I I like put oh
yeah so I'm trying to find them real
quick but all the all the comments just
all the comments like doesn't work if
someone has bad spending habits I
totally disagree Rachel this is
unbelievable advice uh I told you I told
you uh oh my gosh I don't agree we had
joined Accounts at first and then he
just kept spending and spending then my
kids and I couldn't eat didn't have like
basically didn't have didn't have money
for food so we separated so again there
are issues that people have but money is
not
the reason oh someone's like oh I
splurged and got a prenup so now
everything is separate this feels much
better for me in our marriage we go on
and on
but but like there yeah there's just
this this idea that if there are issues
in the marriage right he is spending
everything and won't go to therapy or
um you feel like you have a level of
yours your identity still that it just
feels safer over here if I just keep
this stuff and you go there right like
all of that that's not a money issue
like that's a those are marriage issues
and they're it's coming out as a money
issue that we won't share accounts right
but it's indicating something deeper yes
of what's going on in the marriage
absolutely and you money becomes the
proxy and so if I'm talking to a couple
who's considering getting married and
they won't share accounts
the issue is less about the function of
a checking account right it's more this
will never work if you go in with a wall
built and he goes in with a wall built
and you try to build a community
together it will not work you have to
decide it's the vulnerability I'm going
to open up the drawbridge I'm going to
open up the gates here and we're going
to get both leave and we're gonna go
create something new together
and God Almighty dude the lowest common
I mean the simplest thing is to throw
all your money in the same account right
if you can't figure that out think long
and hard about getting married if you
are married to somebody who is
prohibiting you and your children from
eating that is abuse yeah right go get
help make a phone call that's not about
sharing a checking account together
that's about abuse yes right that is a
totally different problem because there
are ish there are situations like that
absolutely that we're not just like
blindly no regardless of anything no
with if there are there's major
dysfunction in the household and you
have to protect yourself for a reason
again huge marriage issue there but
there's ways to protect it yes uh with
your money because on the flip side the
positive of when you join your accounts
together as a couple that we have found
is that when you do something together
like money that's something that is just
hard in life and and figuring out money
or walking the baby steps getting out of
debt like this is not easy stuff you
really will have to be intentional to
work at it but when you have a spouse
next to you and you guys lock arms and
you see yourselves as a team and you say
we're in this together not only do I
think that you you you achieve your
financial goals so much faster when it's
that mentality like we are in this
together and we're gonna we're running
the same race but something thing
happens there's a there's a level of
just uh excitement and sacrifice all of
that you do together think about the
basketball player that says I don't care
about y'all I'm gonna get my 30 points a
game that team's not gonna win yep right
it's when they all say we're in this
together we're gonna all give we're
gonna all pass we're gonna all shoot the
ball we're gonna all play defense so
that we all win right in the same way it
works in a very kind of shallow way too
it the connection point is there because
you end up talking about everything you
have to you have to talk about it so
you're you're talking you're
communicating which is a point of
connection so that's good this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show
all right up next is Shannon from
Detroit hey Shannon welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me absolutely how
can we help
so I am an analysis paralysis with some
special circumstances
um during college I kind of had what I
refer to as mental breakdown because I
don't know what else to call it but my
anxiety and depression got worse and
then covet happened and I started
getting agoraphobia so luckily I've been
able to talk to some professionals that
have helped me and I'm actually now able
to have a part-time job so I can start
making some money
you're able to leave home
yes now I am um especially I I'm getting
this thank you yeah I'm able to get a
service dog in September so that's
really going to help me too hey that's a
hey that's a hard one like I I know I
keep interrupting I'm sorry but that's a
hard one I want to celebrate that with
you is that cool thank you yes that's
tough man especially on the back end of
kovid getting out and yeah we weaponized
each other during that season and so
good for you I'm proud of you thank you
sorry for interrupting you go ahead go
ahead no you're good so I have since
getting the service dog I have a huge
unexpected cost and since I'm only able
to work part-time for now
um I don't know how to come up with that
cost my parents got like a huge bonus
this past year so they offered the paper
and cash and then just had me pay it
later but I didn't know like I don't
know what to do first I know I have the
thousand dollar emergency fund but do I
pay them back to get my debt cleared
because I don't have I won't have any
student debt or do I continue saving to
rent somewhere or have a house like I
don't know what yeah there's okay so is
the big expense like you said at the
beginning of this the dog the service
dog is that correct yeah okay so how
much is that
it's gonna be sixteen thousand two
hundred sixteen thousand okay what debt
do you have right now Shannon
um I have
just fifteen hundred dollars left from
my last class
um this fall but I have enough cash to
pay for that ahead of time okay so
there's no credit cards or car loans or
anything
no I actually it was introduced to you
guys before
um I even started high school so I tried
to oh well before then and then my
parents had saved up money for me so
that's awesome how old are you Shannon
22 22 okay very cool okay are you at
home right now living at home
yes okay yeah and so you're looking to
move out kind of start your life and
be an adult right that you're just yeah
you're ready to to leave the nest which
is awesome so do you have any do you
have any money saved
um after I graduate I get money that my
parents had set aside for me so between
like working before I got this job and
that I'll have like ten thousand dollars
right after I graduate great and the
service dog is coming in you said
September
yeah is that right okay
so you have about yeah
three months or so
um
yeah to come up with six thousand
dollars how much are you making right
now
um right now I'm making 13.50 an hour
and I work like 25 hours a week so okay
okay so if I were you I would do
priority of what's the most important in
my life to
um
be self-sufficient right and this dog to
me is number one it's even before moving
out
um getting this dog in place because
that dog is really going to be the thing
that I'm from what I'm hearing you and
John correct me if I'm wrong too that's
going to help you really be able to to
work more hours to be able to live
independently and really continue to
live life the way you want to as an
adult is that correct
yeah it is okay and with your particular
response your particular phobia your
particular anxiety response running out
and getting your own place and
immediately re-isolating yourself may be
tough right now does that make sense
yeah and that's how it kind of got worse
when I was in college because I had a
roommate but College was like two three
hours away from my family who I was
really close to so it felt like I was
isolating myself so I would love to like
Rachel saying I'd love you to do this in
the right order which sounds like I'm
gonna delay moving out from home for six
months or seven months and I'm gonna sit
down with Mom and Dad and we're gonna
write this down together so they're on
the same page I'm on the same page we're
all good and think of it less like
you're
this dog is not like a car right they're
not buying you a thing they are
participating in your in really in your
in your health right they're helping
with think of it like a more of a
medical payment than they're buying you
a new bicycle or something okay and so
um we're going to get get this
relationship with this dog and those
things are magical by the way I've seen
some really remarkable turnarounds with
folks I'm going to get really
comfortable with this dog and then I'm
going to in this season I'm going to
start I'm going to spread out my work
hours and I'm gonna start leaning into
that anxious discomfort okay and your
your counselor is probably working with
you on that is that right
yes definitely so we're going to we're
gonna we're gonna end up short
circuiting that anxiety response we're
going to keep leaning into that and
we're gonna have this talk and we're
gonna have Mom and Dad at home and that
sounds like that's a good place it's not
a it's not a like a they're not a part
of the problem right and so then in six
months nine months you're gonna look up
this dog's gonna be fully grown you're
gonna be debt free you can figure out
the payment with you and your parents on
this thing maybe you pay 10 grand of it
they pay the other six or something
they're willing to help you out then
you've saved up money now you're working
full time you've got a full a full-time
partner with this dog and then you're
ready to go get an apartment you see
what I'm saying
yeah and then ah then you can just head
right out right yeah there's no yeah the
urgency I don't want you to have to feel
right now Shannon because there is no
urgency you're I mean besides the dog
and getting that dog in September
but besides that all the other stuff
yeah I mean even if you pause and you
yeah you waited nine months if you
waited till next summer even if it was
12 months you said hey next may my goal
is to be on my own all of that I think
that there's no I think there'd be more
harm to the urgency of doing things out
of order versus just tapping the brakes
and you're good and to continue to heal
but on a kind of a tactical side Shannon
I would I would challenge you just on
what your job is I mean you're you're
making 13.50 an hour
and there's a lot of places that are
paying 20 even up to 25
um maybe with the skill set that you
have and so I would just you know even
just in the next week or two
just look look around and say okay is
there anything that can just up that
because even
getting a seven dollar an hour raise is
going to significantly help you over the
course of of these months as you're
saving up for the dog and then
um and again I don't want to put too
much on you but if you're trying to
think okay how much money how can I get
money as quickly as possible for this
big expense that's the dog that's going
to help me so much in life
um I've heard John so many so many
people doing things from home yeah so I
mean like there's like I don't know if
there's a job that you can pick up for
like two hours in the evenings on your
computer and you can make just a little
bit more money there and and again some
of this feels like a drop in the bucket
when you're like sixteen thousand
dollars but over time do the math MAP it
out and say okay how what can I do in
the short term that's not going to just
damage who I am but really be able to
um help in my healing and give me a
little bit of the confidence there's
there'll be a confidence boost a dignity
that you're going to have Shannon when
you say wow I went and did this like I
saved up this and
um all of it and the fact that your
parents are there willing to help you I
think is amazing and if they're able to
gift you any of that money toward dog
you know and you can kind of figure that
out that's that's awesome too but um but
that tactically I would say yes your
thousand dollars
um emergency fund is is really key but
this dog is going to be like number one
so saving towards that
um as soon as possible I think is huge
good for you proud of you it's awesome
Shannon so so great uh man I feel like
we did one year line of work seeing what
kova did in the shutdown like was did
more more stuff spiked right I mean
everything that I've seen with like
whether it's depression anxiety all of
it yeah it seems like there was a time
when that we're still feeling the
effects right yeah I think we've got a
100 Year turnaround and not to be
pessimistic but
um somebody asked me on an interview a
few a few months ago did I think this
was worse than the 911 tragedy
um and I said yes because after 9 11 we
had a common thing we could point at
they were trying to get us and for this
one what got weaponized was each other
oh and so we got to reconnect with one
another yes that's great all right
thanks for listening to this hour of the
Ramsey Show thanks to Kelly James Ben
Zach Andrew Austin everyone in the booth
I went down my list that's impressive
thank you thank you John thank you for
hosting with me you're welcome oh God
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions this is the Ramsey show where
America hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money I am
Ramsey personality Rachel Cruz here with
me today Dr John deloney taking your
calls this hour about your life your
money your marriage your relationships
your career anything and everything we
are here for you it's a free call
anywhere in the country at triple eight
eight two five five two two five so to
start us off this hours Paul in
Cincinnati hey Paul welcome to the show
hey John Rachel thank you how are you
guys doing today we're doing great how
are you Paul
um I'm feeling pretty stressed and torn
with a family and money situation I was
hoping to get your thoughts and advice
on it yeah we'd love to help what's
what's going on okay so
um I'm wondering if I should quit my
side job to spend that time instead with
my wife and newborn baby girl or should
I keep working the side job considering
we just started baby step two this week
and we have about 245 000 in debt what's
it in
uh 128 of that is mortgage and the rest
is student loans personal loans car
loans credit card okay all the fun stuff
yep yep okay real quick will you break
down all the debt not claim the mortgage
but break do you have the numbers for
your for credit card all that okay
yeah I've got about 1800 in credit card
we have uh
3250 to a personal loan uh about 3 500
left on a car uh student loan for my
wife is about 11
000 a HVAC home improvement loan for
about twelve thousand a parent plus loan
that I agreed to pay back for my mom
that's 16 000 and then my student loans
are about seventy thousand wow you got
you got a little bit of everything Paul
nice little nice little variety what do
you do for a living man
uh I am a manager at a non-profit that
provides free clothing boutique for
foster children oh that's awesome and
how much how much do you make a year
doing that
I make a little over 45
000 and then my wife is a third grade
teacher she makes about 67 000. okay is
she gonna go back
uh she is back
um and she's also in grad school to be a
school counselor okay without cash flow
in that which we're cash flowing it's
cash flowing okay awesome
so the side job was to kind of help pay
for the cash flowing of the grad school
and the added cost of child care
okay so not started it was actually
pretty decent pain but it's on my side
job is I'm a custodian at a local gym
and now that I know how to do everything
and it doesn't take me nearly as long it
just doesn't pay as much because it's
hourly okay
um but you're using that
side gig money from what you said for
child care
uh and grad school so is that money
already is there anything extra that you
have that's going to the debt or is that
that all that money from the side get
going to
um yeah with the budgeting we realized
that we could essentially live on just
one income and we were just kind of
living in that stupid where we just were
spending money that we didn't have on
things that we didn't need yeah
um so we're able to pay toward our
snowball but I'm just I don't want to
make it last any longer from the math
I'm like it's already going to take five
years
I just what's your degree in what's your
degree in Paul
Susan
okay
so
Rachel can I hop in here oh please do
yeah yeah okay Paul I'm gonna just cut
to the chase okay is that cool
yeah okay you're broke
and you're you're scary broke
okay
um I know you know that but I want to
say it that's starkly
this you're gonna have to get a job the
place you work at right now is an
extraordinary mission
and it's like you being there is a gift
to the people that you serve and you are
in a financial position that you cannot
afford to do that type of work right now
and and support your family you have a
an Emergency your house is on fire and
inside your house having a having a
Bible study or cooking food for the
homeless would be great but right now
your house is on fire you need to get
out of the house
okay
okay you're gonna have to find work
where you can get this stuff paid off
fast fast fast
it might mean that we're gonna pause
grad school for a minute because the
house is on fire
it might mean that I'm gonna stop doing
um this part-time job here and I'm gonna
get a full-time job making sixty
thousand and then I'm gonna go work the
late shift from 5 PM to 11 30 at
McDonald's and make 20 bucks an hour on
a sign I saw the other day
I'm gonna work like crazy for 20 20
months 24 months and we're going to get
this thing knocked out so that I can
spend tons of Time full presence no
anxiety no anxiousness no it's all
coming down
the next time you have a air conditioner
fail it's going to be annoying not a a a
a alone a HELOC and then you're going to
be able to breathe around your baby
that's what I'm suggesting okay
yeah that's the level of radical life
transformation your baby deserves you
deserve your wife deserves your marriage
deserves everybody does
I mean sorry no no no it's it because
because it because the mat when you just
look at the math right John does a great
job bringing in the the reality of the
emotional state and what and what's
going on inside of you but but also Paul
the the numbers you just have you guys
just have a small shovel with a really
big hole is kind of what it is right so
I'm just like how can we fill in this
hole of debt faster more efficiently for
you and your family because that's who I
want you taking care of first and
foremost before anyone else and I yeah
whether it's I mean foster care adoption
homelessness uh human trafficking all of
these things in the world
um when we can plug ourselves into those
things and make the world better we are
all for all four but not at the
detriment we gotta get our house out of
your family first and foremost you know
so even if it's four
18 months that you go and work a job at
your car right those but it's paying a
ton and I'm sacrificing what I love and
what my mission is for the moment just
to clear all this out and and wipe it
out then I get to actually what John was
saying I get to breathe and be like okay
we have margin I have margin in my life
now and so yeah I can take a pay cut and
go work somewhere that I really feel
called to because I actually can I can
do that and take care of my family but
the quickest way you're going to change
this scenario Paul really is is is the
income side uh getting it up in the side
gig if there's something that pays more
or you can do it quickly for two hours
and you go over to another side gig and
I know your your initial question though
was do I keep all of that
or spend time with my family and I think
it can be both I think that yes you are
in the middle of sacrifice right now
time wise to clean up this financial
hole that you guys are in by knocking
out these debts and these are some small
debts that's why I loved it like the
credit card debt you're gonna pay that
off you're gonna stay motivated and from
someone whose dad and parents my mom my
dad worked all the time when I was
little all the time Paul doing all this
stuff I mean but I never felt like I had
an absent dad because when he was around
he was present fully with you fully with
me so I think you can still be a great
dad and work your tail off for 18 to 24
months to clear the stud out but I
appreciate your call appreciate the work
that you do what's on your heart because
it's incredible absolutely incredible
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I feel like there's so many rumors and
just Panic around the real estate market
right now uh there's one truth it's all
coming down people think it's gonna
crash and the Great Depression is coming
and it's just there's a lot of a lot of
feelings a lot of emotion around this
topic a lot of opinions around this
topic so next week we're going to do a
free live stream called the real estate
reality check so it's a one-night event
it's Dave Ramsey myself and George
Campbell we're gonna break down the real
estate market and how it actually works
so you can figure out how to navigate it
yourself instead of listening to all
these people from
social media and the news and all of us
I have this opinion we're actually going
to look at facts figures numbers but
we're going to kind of get it's going to
feel like a like a real estate 101 class
in college like we are gonna we're gonna
get into the details because it's really
important to have facts and knowledge
versus just hype and emotion and people
freaking out so we're going to look at
data and talk about hey what does it
look like realistically for you out
there so make sure that you check it out
it's going to be again next Thursday
July 14th the real estate reality check
and you can register for free right now
and get all the answers that you need to
make confident decisions so go to
ramsesolutions.com
realitycheck that's ramseysolutions.com
reality check
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping with the new promo codes
they run every month you'll save even
more use promo code Ramsay to get the
best deal all right today's question
comes from Abby in North Dakota Abby
writes my husband and I are 32 years old
and we have a home worth four hundred
thousand dollars the mortgage is 900
bucks a month with nine years remaining
my husband has epilepsy and has been
unable to work for two years I bought
the property and have been the sole
Breadwinner during our marriage he's
worked on and off at so many jobs I've
lost count I would like to start a
family soon but he wants to sell
everything and live in a van for four
years I wonder if he wants to go down by
the river I don't want to start over
from zero and it seems easy for him to
throw everything away when he's not the
one who worked for it he says he does
not want to die having never had the
chance to travel but that he won't do it
without me do I sell it all and lose my
dream of a stable home or do I tell him
no and live under the weight of his
disappointment oh my gosh yes yeah I'd
be in a stable home and living under the
weight of my husband's disappointment
that's the that's the most Rachel thing
I've heard yeah you can just go be a
disappointed husband I'm living in my
house I will I will take the emotional
toll and have a roof yes I'm not a fan
no and again people live this life this
is a thing people go and get school
buses and they and they retro a lot of
YouTubes they they do it and it's the
thing that they love to do and I think
if the both of you if that was the thing
you love to do and you're like you know
what we're gonna just travel the country
in our van in our bus and live the life
work now let me ask if I find some Wi-Fi
and you can work and take your computer
and it'll be great but if it's not both
of your dreams it turns into a disaster
yes okay I want to work through this
backwards anytime you're in a marriage
and you back yourself into a corner and
you create an either or situation
outside of an abusive situation either I
stay abused or I leave the abuse right
that's an either or
short of that do I sell it all and lose
my dream or do I Crush my husband who's
dying of epilepsy
you've painted yourself in a corner
where it's either a grenade or a nuclear
bomb and I gotta pick because where one
of us is blown up it is yeah this is the
only two options in the entire world so
always and this goes for anybody who's
in a relationship with anybody for
anything do I have to stay and be
miserable forever or do I quit this job
and then go be home let's try the third
option or maybe a fourth let's look for
him right so don't back yourself into a
corner here there's other options here
the second thing is
you all have not as a couple dealt with
epilepsy and what that means you have a
world Abby that you have and you've
created that you want your marriage to
look like you want your home to look
like you have a picture of a family in
your house and you have a husband with a
debilitating neurological condition
on the other side he has a picture of
his life where he feels like he's dying
and I don't she doesn't I couldn't tell
if he's if this is terminal or what but
let's assume that it's not he's created
a picture of living in a van down by the
river and he like let's just let's sell
it all let's go get it
what happens when you both have you both
had different pictures of what your life
is going to look like you start using
language like yours and mine in his and
mine and I did this and he didn't do
that and all of a sudden you are you
know you're sharing a bed with somebody
and you're a foot apart from them but
you're 5 000 miles away from each other
right you're way on the other side of
the world this is not a finance
conversation this is not a do we live in
a van or a house conversation
this is coming to terms with this is our
marriage and this is what our life is
and when we recognize what it is then we
can decide what this marriage could
become together right yeah Abby you have
to decide if you want to be married to a
man with epilepsy who is unable to work
Point Blank and he has to decide if he's
going to continue to be married to you
and your money is y'all's money and
y'all's home is y'all's home right all
of this stuff is we're doing this
together yep right and that's the big
picture and then you know tactically as
you live life out like what are ways to
kind of scratch that itch of him wanting
to travel do you go get an RV and go for
a week like like there are still those
those options in between multiple
options doesn't mean that you can never
ever ever travel or does it mean you
could never ever have kids like it's you
guys there's a medium ground here to get
lots of median of roads in the middle
but through that yes on the Tactical
side as well it's so good all right up
next uh is Zach from Dodge City hey Zach
welcome to the show
hey good afternoon Rachel and John
thanks for taking my call absolutely how
can we help
I'm just looking for a little bit of
insight on
a life slash Financial kind of situation
my wife and I are coming up on
um I've accepted a new position with my
current company that's going to be
moving us across the country
um so just kind of looking for some
insight on if we should sell our house
or not we've been
um remotely managing it with Airbnb for
about the past six to seven months that
I've been traveling but now we're going
to be settling down a little more
permanently just kind of looking for
some insight on whether we should sell
the house and try to buy one where we're
moving whether we should rent the rent's
really high the area we're moving or
maybe live in a camper even we have a
camper currently so that's what I'm
looking for okay where are you guys
moving to
uh the Idaho Falls area okay very cool
um so if I woke up in your shoes Zach I
could tell you what I would what I would
lean towards doing and what I would do I
would sell your house
um where you guys are I would not
continue to be a long distance landlord
it just ends up being a hassle and you
could still get your real estate dreams
somewhere else close by uh so I would
sell your house and then yeah I would I
would I would rent for a year I'm always
a fan of renting at least for a year if
you're somewhere new if you're in a new
area or if you've had a big life change
right like if you've just gotten married
or something like that because
renting it you're you're just in it for
that year and you're not having to like
make one of the largest financial
decisions of your life which is buying a
house for majority of people and so
you're able to say okay we can kind of
look at the area we can figure out what
we like what we don't like this is kind
of what our family is being settled into
and then that even gives you some some
bandwidth to even save to that you're
not attached to if the heating and air
goes out taking care of you know the
issues that a house comes with you're
you're not going to have that as a
renter the landlord will take care of
that so again there's just a little less
responsibility moving to a new city when
you're renting so I like the idea of
renting or living in your if you guys
want to live in your camper you could
totally do that if you're comfortable
doing that but
um I would do that and then look up in a
year after you've moved and say okay
what do we want to do do we want to do
we want to buy do you want to yeah the
question I would ask is if you lived in
Idaho Falls
would you get how to do an internet
search and buy a rental property in
Dodge City Kansas to manage
probably not I'm actually in Dodge City
for work okay and so it's kind of a
yeah yeah like you wouldn't do that
right he would he would buy houses
around you right and so think of it that
way now that you're leaving you've got
some some Roots there it's also tempting
to Rachel to hang onto those roots when
we live somewhere yeah I'd say yeah sell
the house pull up the roots and go do
life elsewhere yep absolutely great call
Zach thanks for the thanks for the
question this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz with Dr John deloney hosting
today and up next is Anastasia from
Jacksonville Florida hey Anastasia
welcome to the show
hi guys thanks for taking my call
absolutely how can we help
so my question is about how can I
protect myself and not compromise my
standards in dating relationships ah
great question sounds like John
relationship expert John deloney can
help I uh
okay is this is this coming from a
particular issue something happened
right in
what's the basis of the call
I have had some
tried my tried my hardest to do the
right thing my whole life and it just
you know hasn't worked out too well but
um I got out of a bad uh my second
marriage which is another bad marriage
last year
I was on track to and I I was like
listen I'm not kidding I listen to the
podcast like non-stop every day I have
not missed one John baloney show like I
I'm clearly not helping
you should maybe listed a different
podcast I'm not doing very good
Anastasia well that's the thing I'm
having this cognitive dissonance between
what I know I need to do and what I
actually do okay so like I met someone I
I fell for him right stealing but I had
these deal breakers up front I've caved
on like most of them or whatever and I
just don't know how it is that I keep
falling in this trap of not like holding
my boundaries in order to like either
yeah what happened in your in your last
marriage like in in in one sentence what
happened
um
got married for the wrong reasons and
there was a lot of what is that what
does that mean for money good looks he
was a great kisser like why'd you get
married
um basically not to go too far into it
but there was some lying based on they
didn't share things about themselves
before we got married and and and we
were kind of you know
not Head Over Heels or anything but we
were gonna try it but there was some
deal breakers that happened and I had to
leave for my mental health okay
um
ultimately
you've probably heard the saying we we
marry our unfinished business have you
ever heard that
yeah the things that we need to work in
ourselves
we often subconsciously look to have
that puzzle piece met
through somebody else
and the problem is they are doing the
same thing with us and we get together
and we create a dance and we realize
that no external entity can fill up a
hole that's inside of us
and then it implodes and then we go do
it again and we go do it again and we go
do it again
and until you decide
that you and you alone have intrinsic
value from the inside out
and begin living that way
you create an identity that says I have
Anastasia has value
not only the way I quote unquote try to
do the right thing but I do the right
thing because it's the most honoring
thing to me because I'm worth the right
thing I'm worth taking care of my body
I'm worth being a steward of my mental
health I'm worth great relationships
where I can laugh and be safe I'm worth
those things that's why I do the quote
unquote right things
not because the right things are in and
of themselves intrinsically the right
things it's because they work right they
make our lives better and so I'm going
to do these things because I have value
and then I'm gonna meet somebody not
because like Renee Zellweger and uh you
complete me um like you complete me no
you're with me and together you and I
are going to create something totally
new and that's a completely different
proposition that's not about healing
that's about creation and that's a
different world see what I'm saying
well yeah I thought I was doing that
like I thought I was there no but you're
still doing it with another person
you're trying to drink the right alcohol
to stop being an alcoholic
because I finally felt whole just me and
and I finally felt like I was like
feeling really good and loving myself
you know what I mean yeah and then I
felt like I didn't even
and you felt you felt healthy so then
you went and got into another
relationship and then within that
relationship you started compromising
your yeah and then and then you're
thinking why why do I keep doing this
yeah so let me let me challenge you
anytime somebody this is just it's a
trigger for me when somebody says I
started loving myself and feeling good
my next question is what were you doing
differently
because loving yourself and feeling good
is very much in your head
and it's the actions that heal us
okay it's the things we do
and we can get some space from from Rage
and we can get some space from abuse and
we can get some space from dysfunctional
relationships and our bodies begin to
breathe again and we mistake that for
healing
that's not healing that's just not hurt
that's not affirmatively hurting anymore
I'm not hitting myself with a hammer
anymore that doesn't mean my arms better
I've got to do something different okay
see what I'm saying
and so yeah you get a chance to breathe
you had a chance to smile and laugh a
little bit again
you felt good and then you can start
doing the hard stuff like dealing with
the past traumas that I know are there
like exercise and move in my body and
getting with some friends and having
some girlfriends that I can just go
laugh with and hang out with
and then your body begins to heal and
then you're going to meet somebody you
see what I'm saying
yeah you just gotta decide I'm gonna do
it in that order
am I guess it's so deep because I I have
feelings for this new person and now I
feel like I don't know how to back out
of it because I feel like
you know
do I work with them and keep on trying
but I'm having to like like all your
marriage and money stuff is like not
diving too well with them and it's like
trying to convince them I'm like I'm
just working too hard here
yeah because in my head I'm like
relationships are work but it's not from
the front end of trying to put these
pieces together and trying to make it
like right yeah yeah I'm not the
relationship expert but in my head it
feels it does feel like you're trying to
make something work that is not
naturally working there should be a
level of something naturally is
connecting and that we naturally agree
on values you're putting way too much in
the wheelbarrows just getting out of the
gate just go have fun and go bowling
you know what I mean like like go go
enjoy your life laugh often find joy
go to a movie without a guy both sure
but like go with the guy but it doesn't
have to be like hey while we're here are
we going to share bank accounts what do
you what is your opinions are like you
know what I mean like
but eventually she's gonna have to ask
those questions that's right and then
when that happens and it doesn't jive
then you don't want to compromise no
absolutely the future where you're
thinking oh gosh this really isn't but
she but she needs to chill a little
that's what you're saying yes usually
and tell me if I'm wrong Anastasia on
the back end of multiple relationships
that have imploded on you okay
it's really tempting to try to
short-circuit the process and get all
that crap out up front so I don't have
to go through the pain on the back end
yeah that's right exactly what I was
trying to do I was trying to like you
can't do it that way and I hate that for
you but that's just not the way they
work you can't do it
that's like getting a new
apart from a job and you get you another
job and you just show up to your third
job and you go I want four years of
salary right now give it to me now and
then I'll work real hard and they're
like that's not really how that works
you can't do it like that and it's a
recipe for you being frustrated and the
person you're dating being like Oh I I
just want to go why does she want my tax
returns can we just go to the movies can
we go to the movies I mean I'll trade
you a Ted lasso for your FPU videos if
that's gonna mean so I mean I'll do it
right that's what we're talking about I
want you to just take 30 off take 40 off
and breathe and I want you to find some
people in your life that you can be
fully you with and they're going to
challenge you to begin to act
differently that's good let that
confidence grow from the inside out okay
you're worth it and you're worth it and
so is FPU those videos are wonderful a
great date material geez Louise first
date don't compromise your values
Finance Peace University don't
compromise your value
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I am at
Rachel Cruz with Dr John deloney and
it's a free call anywhere in the country
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five up next on the phones is Drew
from Greenville hey Drew welcome to the
show
hey how's it going we're doing great
doing great how can we help
so I have completed baby step three nice
congratulations
appreciate it and um and um I want to
move on to either baby step 3B or should
I do four five and six with baby step
six being the the the saving for the
house down payment
are you guys looking to to move are
y'all wanting to buy a house
uh well I'm I'm an active duty Marine
stationed overseas okay um we're gonna
be there for at least two more years
thank you for your service I appreciate
it and when we move back to the States
I'll have about a year left before uh
before I retire okay and so I didn't
know if if if
staying in baby step 3B for two years if
that's too long or should I you know do
like a year and then go to four five and
six or or should I just capitalize
because we make pretty good money living
overseas right now so I just capitalize
on on that two years and through the 3B
and pretty much get our pretty much not
3B out of the way or or what's your I'm
just looking for y'all's opinion on that
yeah absolutely so when you move back to
the states in two years you guys more
you're you're wanting to buy a home
right that's going to be probably going
to be happening is that correct yeah or
when you move back for one year could
you just live on base for 12 more months
and then go whenever you're get a more
permanent residence after that can then
you buy a house then right that's you
yes sir that's what it would be so when
we when we move back it won't be that
year before I retire it won't be where
we would like to settle down
you're staring down three years right
yeah you got three years correct yeah
okay and do you guys know where you want
to end up
what part of the country we'd like to
end up yes yeah we'd like to end up in
the upstate of South Carolina okay we're
uh where I'm calling from now but
um you know I guess it depends on what
the housing market looks like totally
anything else yeah I mean I think if I'm
you drew I would I would save something
and I would kind of look and again like
you said we don't we don't know we don't
have a crystal ball we don't we don't
know but from the facts we've gathered I
think it's still gonna it's gonna look
similar probably in three years it'll
probably you know home values think will
still continue to increase a little bit
I don't think it's gonna We're not gonna
see what we've seen the last two years
so if I were you just kind of for the
fun of it just to get an idea is just
you know go online and
see what's being sold in that area that
you guys want to live and what kind of
house you're like okay this would be
ideal for us here's how much it is now
what would a five percent ten percent
fifteen percent twenty percent down
payment look like how much would that be
and and and kind of do the math to
figure okay what if we just saved that
put that in a money market account
didn't touch it and then start it and
then press play on four five and six
um that's probably what I would what I
would do and I would be curious how fast
you guys could save up that down payment
yeah that's what that's what I think the
two years two years have put us right at
a hundred thousand that we could
probably save okay and that would be
probably 20
um
or or more yeah based on when we okay so
maybe it's even that you saved 75 000 so
you can go ahead and start four five and
six uh it's kind of whatever you guys
feel comfortable with
um but but anywhere in that range yeah
where you've already done it and you're
like okay this is how much we can save
this feels like the right amount of down
payment for the type of house we're
gonna want as of what we see right now
um and then and then yeah press play on
that four five and six are your earnings
overseas are they are they tax free
no no we'll still pay tax the portions
of it is based on like the the cost of
living that they they allow us to have
um that's tax-free but but everything
else is taxable okay and you mentioned
the the word retirement do you have
little kids that you're saving for
college funds for
right now I am I'm putting I have the GI
Bill okay which is going to probably
take care of my daughter she's the
closest one she's nine and then my son's
five but uh if he's anything like me
he's a knucklehead he's not gonna go to
college but I'm not going to sell them
short so there you go okay so here
here's Rachel tell me if I'm wrong on
this it feels like
we got three B you got four five and six
and then there's This Magic Moment to
save to just crash course a lot of cash
over two years overseas some of its some
of it's tax free some of it's regular
got your living expenses comped in some
areas this seems like a moment to really
just
back up cash right and then you come
back and really begin to play with
reality again and what you want to do
yeah that might not be the best way to
deal with that
um how old are you drew
school that was 37 37 okay okay that's
good
there you go I'll be 37 this year well
you've got a five-year-old that suddenly
turns will be a seven-year-old that it's
not like you've got a 16 year old that's
about to be an 18 year old when it comes
to how are we going to deal with college
you see what I'm saying
right right and you got the GI bill so
at
I might lean that way yeah just to save
yeah you guys just stockpile some cash
and then once you feel good about you
know even if you hit that hundred
thousand and you're okay maybe we can
open up a Roth IRA that that whatever
that one year or maybe maybe do your
roths both years but keep on right so
you're doing a little bit of both but
yep yep I think either way Drew I think
you guys are gonna you're gonna turn out
just fine the the situation um because
what one year isn't going to absolutely
implode your retirement you're gonna be
okay even if you didn't fund retirement
for these you know two years
um but I would save up for that house
that down payment because that's gonna
be that's gonna be a wonderful gift when
you guys come back to the States and
after retirement and after living on
base for that year to be able to press
play and put a good down payment on a
home uh is gonna is gonna feel great so
yeah I would say that up for two years
and then year three during retirement I
would I would press play on a couple of
um retirement investing in it so and let
me let me give you this one character
note
um Drew
usually when we're talking to people
with the with the character that you
have which is a person of high
intentionality you're talking about a
decision you're going to be making right
now it's going to impact you in three
years that's how intentional you are
you're taking 36 months ahead
and you're thinking long term for your
children
you're going to be okay
it's the folks that are thinking five
minutes down the road 10 minutes down
the road not 36 months down the road
that we are really concerned about yeah
say hey hey look on the plane so you're
talking you're nudging at the edge of
the margins here man you are gonna be
great yep you're doing great true great
job thanks thanks again for your service
all right up next is Liam from Lexington
we're right up against the clocks to go
quick hey Liam how can we help
hey uh I'm a 21 year old uh I guess
Foreman at the moment at a company and I
owe the opportunity to go to school at
uh the college I want to go to for
almost nothing
um the military is paying for them in
the National Guard
right now what's that I said wonderful
thank you thanks for your service oh
yeah
yeah it's my pleasure
um but right now I have a really good
paying job I earned about 25 an ounce
and I was just wondering like I'm
constituting between uh going to college
which I've wanted to do what's what's
the job I mean what's the what's the
career what's the where do you need to
go study the career is business
administration with a specialization in
project management now
and so in the future like I have the
Practical side down of the the degree
but not the actual uh credential the
provincial side of things so Rachel you
Rachel Rachel you and I may disagree if
you're my son or you or me or you were
my brother
what I would tell you is go to college I
was going to say the same go get the
degree this is a remarkable opportunity
to get a degree with a a an extensive
Roi attached to it for basically nothing
and
um and it's a school you want to go to
you're going to work hard you're going
to get this stuff knocked out and 25 an
hour is going to be way in your rearview
mirror when you combine your Tactical
knowledge plus this new information
you're going to learn and by the way go
in open-minded because you there's a lot
you're going to learn and then you're
gonna have the credential on top of it
man I'd tell you to go to college
absolutely Liam I would say the same
thing I'd go to college I would do it
and then you can come out with a
wonderful degree that everyone's looking
for project manager so uh you're you're
picking a really really smart degree as
well so great job don't borrow a penny
don't borrow a penny yes go debt free
debt free all right that's that puts the
sour of the day room of the Ramsay show
in the books thanks Kelly James Finn
Zach Andrew and Austin and John deloney
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18 million people listen to the
Ramsey show every week a lot of those
people listen on one of our 600 plus
radio stations across the country to
find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions that this is the Ramsey show
where we're here to have a conversation
about your life and your money I am
Ramsay personality Rachel Cruz on this
hour with Dr John deloney and it's a
free call anywhere in the country at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five your intro is so gentle for a
Ramsay show is it does it feel like calm
and soothing well Dave's like live from
America
America's headquarters Rachel's like hey
everybody live from the head coach I
like that Virginia slim the grab a wine
cooler Physicians we'll talk about your
life have a seat and your money some
things pull up a chance just gentle pull
up a chair open your mind in your heart
my cortisol is running low to quite low
David David is up next there's a little
Spike I showed you David let's do this
David from Denver hey welcome to the
show David
hi guys um you know what fruit of the
spirit is actually gentleness so I kind
of appreciate that dude I'm so glad that
you are the call we picked up for this
guy
he appreciate
it
he appreciates it we talk a lot about a
lot of stressful stuff on the show John
a little gentleness doesn't hurt anymore
I love it all right David how can we
help
um so I was in a relationship I was in a
marriage for 10 years and then my wife
left and it's kind of crazy am I in my
grief I rushed into another relationship
um
my new girlfriend is pregnant
um and we're trying to figure out the
best way to merge families now
um I was on my way to getting out that
um
um I was paying off and I was doing a
lot of things now but now
um with the
choice of
um joining the families and everything
that's going on I just want to know
what's best to prepare
um
because she lives in York and I actually
live here in Denver Colorado so um okay
what do y'all think are y'all gonna get
married or are you like no not that but
we're gonna
um no I do want to like okay hold on
real quick David David you're using a
lot of cryptic language and kind of
bouncing around okay
like everybody's grown up here just like
shoot it straight like you live in this
town you live in this town your
girlfriend's pregnant and now you all
are thinking about what what comes next
um yeah we're gonna merge our family
what does that mean what does that mean
that you merge companies what are you
doing with your families y'all getting
married
yeah we want to get married okay and um
you know be uh be a family this one
family okay all right
so is she coming to Denver are you going
to go to New York
um I really want her to come to Denver
um
my you know my daughter I have a
daughter too so she's here and um
but she has her her doubts
um
she lives uh she she wants me to come to
New York the cost of living is lower in
New York
um but I find that
um even though the cost of living is
higher here in Colorado
they pay more you know to compensate for
the inflation so
um I'm the only one working she does not
work
um she does have a savings saved up and
I'm actually in debt trying to get out
um
everything okay back there
David
okay uh are you there
yeah I'm here I apologize about that
yeah you're good you're good no worries
no worries okay
so which so what what do you need help
from us you're calling the Ramsey show
what do you are you are you what do you
need
so I just want to best
um I wanted some maybe some insight on
on how to best prepare
um for for come joining a family yeah
yeah brother y'all aren't even close to
that
you're not even near that right now
you
she hasn't y'all haven't even agreed to
be in the same Community together in the
same state together on the same Hemet
side of the of the country together
okay
how do you combine families that I mean
at least we've got to get the same zip
code
and so if I'm you I'm getting on a plane
and I'm gonna go fly down and sit in a
room and have a very grown-up adult
conversation with somebody that I I just
created a life with
and we're going to talk about what's
next we're not going to talk about
savings accounts yet we're not going to
talk we're going to talk about what's
next
who's gonna who's gonna change their
life
everyone this is everybody's life's
different now everybody's life's
different
is she gonna move to Colorado with you I
don't care about the cost of living and
how much inflation is she gonna move
with you so that you can be by your
daughter because your daughter's not
going to leave this Colorado
um or are you gonna pack up and leave
your current daughter to go be with your
new child
right so you see what I'm saying like we
have to have some very basic nuts and
bolts grown-up conversations
and then we're going to get into she I
I've heard nothing that she's even
remotely ready to marry you or merge
families with you
um well she is she is and I'm sorry I
left that out okay yeah mainly she she
is and she um the the plan is to to live
here
um I just have some doubts because the
cost of living is cheaper over there but
I believe you know in terms of resources
that God will provide whatever but
um the plan is to move her down here
um David is she going to be leaving kids
there or will she she's not she will not
be leaving kids
um they're gonna come with her their
kids are not not involved okay how many
kids does she have I'm just curious she
has she has currently she has three and
then we're gonna have a four okay
so then there'll be five of us
um yes and so you since you have a
daughter there
um
I
I could care less what inflation is I'm
gonna live in the same as close to my
daughters I possibly can I have a
six-year-old there is no amount of
inflation that's going to take me away
from my daughter okay so let's consider
that problem solved geographically okay
and now it's about you figuring out what
kind of money is it going to take for
you to earn to take care of this family
when it comes to the relationship side
you and your girlfriend who's soon to be
your new wife are going to have to
create something entirely new
you're not taking you're not blending
this family with this one y'all are
making something totally new there's
going to be pieces of those other
families that go with you those three
kids dads tell us a a vote in their life
more than likely uh your ex-wife or the
mother of your other child has a voice
into your life so there's gonna be other
people speaking into your new world but
y'all are creating something totally new
and so look at it as an opportunity to
completely clear the deck and build
something beautiful and new okay the
more you try to
well this is the in this and bring
baggage from it the more you're gonna
you're gonna I'm trying to think of the
right way to say this no you well you've
said it before to me in a kind of a
different way of like after 9 11 when
the towers they didn't take the same
metal and tried to rebuild the same town
that's right they they got rid of
everything and bought something and
built something new so you're building a
whole new and that has to be your
mindset which I think is we're doing
something totally new yeah absolutely
absolutely thanks for the call David
good luck with everything this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting today with Dr John
deloney all right up next is Rachel from
Kansas City hey Rachel love your name
welcome to the show
hi Rachel and Dr John how are you guys
we're doing great sure would have been
better if you were named John but go
ahead just kidding go ahead what's up my
parents second choice
awesome how can we help
well I was hoping you guys could help me
learn some tools to stay motivated On
and On Track when completing the baby
steps
um I'm in baby step number two I haven't
gotten very far I've only paid out for a
couple of small debts I have my thousand
dollar emergency fund but it seems like
every time I save up a little bit of
money to pay or to start paying off
another debt I somehow convinced myself
that I need something so I go out I
spend my money and then I come home and
I'm completely ashamed of myself scold
myself a little bit and then I move on
and say I'll do better next time and
then next time comes I just do it all
over again
um and my I have three little girls at
home my oldest is about to turn 15 this
month and it got me thinking like oh my
gosh she's gonna be driving in the year
I really need to get my crap together
because I need to set a better example
for them and just hoping you guys can
help me get on track and stay on track
so I was doing a practicum for my one of
the cool things about going back to
school when I was as an old guy is I had
to do a practicum again I had to be an
intern again and and I was doing my
internship with this guy named Dr
Michael Gomez a brilliant child
psychologist and we were working with
traumatized kids and he was about 10
maybe 15 years younger than me he's just
so fond and we were walking out of her
room one day when we were working with a
little child who was saying some really
abhorrent things like some really rough
things about women and I happen to have
a little boy at the time
and I was would ask questions that were
cloaked
um psychology questions really I was
just asking Like This brilliant person
how can I be a better dad right and so
we were walking from one room to another
and I said well what do you tell a
little boy so that he'll respect women
when he grows up
and he he was on to me really fast and
Dr Gomez said this and it has stuck with
me forever he said I don't know you can
tell him whatever you want to
but if you wanted to respect women just
know he's watching everything you do
so if you want him to respect women
um treat your wife right and then he
just walked into the next room and I was
like oh no and Minnie can we pop back
out in Middle there he's like and make
sure you take care of the waitress and
tip I mean he just started rattling all
these things off and so here's what I'm
telling you
quote unquote getting your crap together
or I need to start setting a good
example you've got 15 years that your
daughter has absorbed you
all of it how do you respond to
challenges what you do when you get
frustrated sounds like you spend when
you're feeling less than or when you're
feeling frustrated or whatever
what we need to do now is have a direct
hard conversation with your 15 year old
that says I've modeled X
and from this point forward I'm going to
start doing different I just had one of
these with my son
about like I'm just a kind of a chaotic
hurricane of a mess when it comes to
just throwing stuff around and I had a
set I sat down with him and said I've
modeled for you uh what poor
organizational skills look like and I'm
making a change and you're going to be
uncomfortable during this change because
it's going to disrupt the way we do life
but I haven't I've let you down as your
dad we just had this conversation a few
weeks ago
and then you've got to make some really
tactical shifts in how you respond and
dig your life
okay I is that fair
that is fair I was going through my
playing through it and thinking like
what is he gonna say what are they gonna
say to me and that did not pop up I am
glad that you surprised me absolutely
yeah and I think there's something to
Rachel about having that come which I
love that John said that because she's
15. she know I mean she's 15 so she's 15
but she's also 15. like she she has her
head on her yeah she knows what's going
on
and there's a level of humility too as a
parent to sit down and just kind of say
out loud like man I hate that I did that
and I hate that this is you know X Y and
Z that I know that this is this is my
knee-jerk behavior and this is what
you've seen in your life and I want to
do better having a parent with that
level of humility there's something that
could even change in y'all's
relationship Rachel with you and your
daughter like there's just something
beautiful that can happen because you
kind of open that door to be like I'm
human too I'm human too and I mess up
and presenting that to her is is amazing
and then what John said in another call
a few segments ago and then actually
doing the action changing your
environment putting putting yourself in
other situations where you're not taking
the money you know tactically and going
and shopping with it but versus paying
off the debt like all that you know can
get fixed but that
um yeah foundation will just shift in
your head of knowing that yeah more is
caught and taught she's she is going to
be watching all of your kids are going
to be watching you and you can say
whatever you want but those actions it's
huge that's it why do you um why do you
spend
um I really feel like my emotions drive
my spending so like when I'm happy I
guess I want to continue the good time
right and be happier and then when I'm
upset or mad or stressed out I feel like
shopping might make me happy and going
to spend money
um I think it's very emotionally driven
so what are some things you could do
today
that would put some hurdles between you
your emotional self and your acting self
in counseling we call it the gap between
stimulus and response
I feel this need to keep this thing
going but I know that I got to get up at
6am and go to work tomorrow I'm gonna
have to pay this credit card bill in 28
days
what are some things you can do right
now and you're going to help millions of
people by just rattling off one or two
that you could put in between you your
feeling and that action
maybe I could
um I set a rule for myself saying no if
I feel like no rules no rules too easy
cancel Amazon Prime today for 30 days
okay
take your debit card out of your wallet
okay take it out
just don't carry it with you
unless you're going to a grocery store
and then you're coming home
make it to where I will have to go ask
somebody to borrow money in a bar to
keep this thing going right or I'm have
to reach across the pedal Tavern and ask
whoever if I can borrow some money right
whatever it is you're doing put some
obstacles in front of you and then bring
your daughters along with you
create a budget and every week sit down
with your daughters
um is Dad around
I'm remarried so there's that bad lives
in the home okay so bring make it a
family affair we're all in on this and
you're gonna have 15 year olds that
can't wait to point out mom's flaws and
so like she's gonna be like do we have
enough is this in the budget is this the
budget right so you're gonna bring
everybody along but what you're doing is
you're creating a hurdle of
accountability you're gonna have a lot
of eyes you're gonna invite a lot of
eyes to be watching your actions okay
take some steps I gotta reach out and
call I've done this I gave my wife my
debit card for a season because I was
out of control and I had to call my wife
as though she was my mommy and at
because I had to learn to do things
differently right and it was the
long-term play was much more important
than my little precious ego and my
little precious feelings and emotions in
that in those moments
is that fair okay that's fair I'm glad
you guys brought the humility piece into
it I think that's a huge problem for me
as well I feel like I always I just want
my kids to think that you know they have
everything that they need Mommy will get
them whatever they want yeah and and I
guess having that conversation with them
and being like look that's just not the
way it works yeah
one of the best definitions of humility
I've heard is that humility is not
thinking less of yourself but it's
thinking of yourself less
so you've been thinking less of yourself
when you've messed up and you're beating
yourself up so humility is not God I'm
just terrible I screwed up or I mean
there's a level of just accountability
of yeah here is what really has happened
factually in my life and the choices
I've made and I have to deal with those
but true humility is thinking less of
yourself and that's what you're doing
you're wanting to get out of debt you're
wanting to create a better life for your
girls you told us that on the call and
so demonstrating that humility that your
life it is less about me and it is more
about serving my family and this is what
this that's gonna be the motivation that
I'm taking as I'm making these new
changes so hang on the line Rachel uh we
are going to give you
Financial Peace University and we're
going to give you every dollar app for a
year we're going to give you the whole
shebang for you to start with your kids
and you're gonna work you're going to
let them watch the videos with you y'all
gonna go through this thing together and
you are going to teach them what
humility looks like and that's going to
be a gift that's going to be a legacy
changer it's great great call Rachel
thanks for the question this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so let me ask you a question when you
think of a millionaire what kind of job
do you picture is it like this
high-powered executive position like a
VP or a CEO well here's the thing only
15 percent of millionaires actually have
jobs like that the reality is the top
five careers for millionaires in America
are engineer accountant teacher manager
and attorney
that's just one of the surprising things
that my team found out when we conducted
the largest study of millionaires ever
done and they talked to tens of
thousands of millionaires to find out
who they are and how they achieve that
goal and our study made it clear that to
become a millionaire you've got to
invest wisely and a big part of that is
actually getting good investing advice
so you want to work with an investing
Pro who you can trust and who will walk
with you to teach you the options that
are right for you and my team recommends
trustworthy vetted investing pros from
all over the country we call them smart
Vester Pros so to get in touch with the
smart Professor Pro in your area go to
ramseysolutions.com
smart investor Pro and start Building
Wealth today that's ramseysolutions.com
smartvester
all right up next we have Garrett in
Green Bay Hey Garrett welcome to the
show
hi Garrett how can I help
I just wanted to say uh John I really
loved your book uh read through it in
like two days thank you thank you thank
you but my question today is I had a
401k at my last employer and I got let
go
um and that ended up just becoming a
rollover
um Ira
um so I'm trying to figure out if I
should move it into like a Roth or if I
should pull that money out to pay off my
debts it's about three thousand dollars
okay yeah I would not I would not pull
it out
um because you'll be hit with a lot of
penalties and taxes there yeah I would
just roll it over to a traditional
IRA and sit down with a with you know we
just talked about smart investor Pros
right right before this call
um or an investing professional that you
trust
um and sit down and do that but that's
yeah I would roll it over to a
traditional IRA okay the only reason I
was asking is because I could be
debt-free then by next month
yeah how much debt do you have
uh well we I had we had about 60 000
um and we're down to like the last five
thousand oh awesome congratulations
don't do it no it's not working I know
it's so tempting I know it's so tempting
January then or
for the next 60 days go Berserker Style
go get like go Uber at night and when
you get off of ubering go work the late
shift at McDonald's for 15 20 bucks an
hour like go Berserker for 60 days and
get this done
well my wife would not like that you
know what she would really like those
you to stop being ding dong be debt free
yes see I told you John Byrne that's
what we say in my house my kids would go
ooh Dad burned mom burn gotcha so go
just say for 60 days honey I'm tired of
this I'm gonna get it done we're so
close to the end we're just gonna Sprint
to the end and look at your house find
five things to sell on Facebook
Marketplace bring in an extra couple
hundred just be done man just be done
just be done you got it Garrett I feel
it
you in
I'll put them on hold on okay sorry
sorry I'm sorry you're right we're gonna
have a moment there but where are you
going Rachel all right up next we have
Don in Chicago hey Don welcome to the
show
hi Dr John and Rachel thank you so much
for taking my call absolutely how can we
help
okay yeah
um first I want to thank you both I
wouldn't be in the financial situation I
am now uh without your program so thank
you for all you do oh thank you Don well
you did it you did the work so
congratulations
thank you okay well um unfortunately I
am going through a divorce and my
divorce will be final final later this
month and my house or our house is
actually selling later this month as
well so it's a crazy time right now
um so what I'm trying to figure out is
my next step I work remotely so I can
basically go anywhere so I'm trying to
make a wise decision on what my next
step will be as far as my living
situation
so I have like four different options
that I've kind of been looking into and
I'll give you just a brief description
of my financial situation as well
um I make around 105 000 a year and
after we split everything in half I'll
have about 260 well about 315 000 in
cash
and I'll have about 250 000 between like
a 401k and a Roth and no debt
so that's a little bit of an idea how
old are your situation
and 48. ah jeez I'm can I just say I'm
sorry this I hate this for you what a
mess yeah what a mess yeah yeah
thank you so much
um I have one actually this is my second
divorce unfortunately but she's from my
previous marriage and she's in college
so just one and she's in college so
so yeah so that's the financial
situation what's your living options and
stuff that you were
very expensive right now so um my family
has been very gracious my sister and my
parents both have offered for me to live
there even temporarily even if it's for
a month or two just to kind of get on my
feet and think clearly and figure out
where I want to go
um another option I have is I have the
potential to be a sorority house
director at the University where my
daughter attempts and in that position
it's a paid position and from what I
understand it pays about two thousand
dollars a month and I would be able to
continue my remote position from there
and I get free lodging free utilities
the food they have a chef so food is
covered as well
and um I've kind of felt like there have
been different things that have happened
that made me feel like God is pointing
me in that direction but so after being
in a very controlled marriage I'm not
sure if that's the way this uh move so
don let me let me let me hop in here uh
because we're gonna run up against the
clock here
um first don't buy a house
give yourself a minimum of six months
preferably a year okay okay ever you are
48 you're yeah clearly brilliant and
good at what you do you're making great
money and another grenade went off
right yeah and you're out of your home
you're out of your partnership you're
out of your marriage you're out of all
the stuff let some of that smoke clear
okay the second thing is I actually did
what you just said my wife and I and a
two-year-old moved into a residence hall
with 170 college men and women
and it was
bananas and it was chaos and we paid off
six figures of debt doing it
and so what I tell you is it was ended
up changing our lives in so many ways
because we ended up living smaller where
our houses were getting increasingly
bigger and then this showed us so we
could live much smaller it just changed
a lot about our marriage for the better
okay so if you can handle it and hang
man go live a wild adventure okay can I
jump in go for it because here's the
thing though Don you have no debt you
have you have three hundred thousand
dollars in cash and what I'm saying is
it's a place there's no lease it's a
place just to sit yeah so unless you
want to deal with the story now if
you're sacrificing to get out of a
financial hole and there's a reason like
there's a like that makes total sense to
me but she said she's getting she feels
like she's getting called to this which
I always want to check that but okay
yeah do you feel like this is an
adventure yes but in my head I'm like
listen or you just go find a great one
bedroom and be and it's quiet I don't
know I don't know well see that that's
my dilemma I mean I feel what do you
want to do either time neither one is
right or wrong near my daughter hold on
hold on yeah here's what I don't want
you to do I don't want you to go run to
the nearest person
and and I don't want your daughter to be
responsible for your healing
no oh I totally agree with that and so
right I would steer less from having a
purpose and more towards healing and
figuring out what comes next
if this is an adventure for you and it's
just not like you're the kind of person
that's going to go with the sorority my
wife and I were the kind of people who
would go live in a residence hall that's
just that's just who we are we're just a
little bit crazy yeah and so if you're a
person who is
gonna go live an adventure go get it if
you are doing this you could be by your
daughter and that's starting to make me
feel uncomfortable a little bit I'd
rather see you pay an overpriced
one-bedroom apartment for six months
because you got the money to do it and
then heal and then figure out what comes
next it's great thanks for the call Don
good luck this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day is first
Timothy 6 6-7 but godliness with
contentment is great gain
before we brought nothing into the world
and we can take nothing out of it
things turn out best for people who make
the best of the way things turn out John
puddin it's pretty good
I like you being in awe as you're
reading it it was good it's like no way
things that's a great way of saying it
though things turn out best for the
people who make the best of how things
turn out
coach you should have said he's the best
is he a coach I don't even know who he
is the driver's coach of all time Izzy
sorry John yes all right hey you know
those moments when you're sitting right
next to somebody but you feel a thousand
miles apart I'm not talking to you
Rachel but it does feel that way some of
you are feeling that way right now
listen we've got to put our phones down
we've substituted deep and meaningful
conversations for binge watching Netflix
together and scrolling social media you
deserve better relationships and that
means having better conversations and we
have to acknowledge we don't have the
skills anymore to do that that's why I
created questions for humans they're
conversation starters that will help you
disconnect from your screens and
actually connect and have fun with the
people you care about we launched the
first edition of these cards a few
months Munch a few months a few months
back and the first run sold out the
second run sold out the Third Run sold
out and they've been flying off the
shelves ever since and people have been
asking for more topics so we took the
hint and now we have new conversation
cards we've added girls night guys night
dating parents and teens you should have
seen the people in the room working on
the girls night cards it was a riot
that's so funny workplace additions to
the lineup and all of them will get you
spending time laughing together learning
things unexpected people have said
they're crying together building deeper
and stronger relationship so pick up one
two or all of the new questions for
humans conversation starters and start
having fun and you can find them at
ramseysolutions.com So Courtney
dexterous and I we did a we were doing
something and a few of them were there
for the girls night so one of the
questions was how long could you survive
like in the wild like if you're just out
there how long could you survive So
Courtney was like oh I can't remember
what she said seven hours I was like no
I was like I can go four days so I was
on the air with Dave and we were talking
about questions for humans so I told
them that story and I was like how long
do You Think You'd Survive day it's like
till high tide
I was like oh my gosh because I wasn't I
wouldn't stop living I'm just keep
living I was like yeah but if you could
like have a buzzer and tap out he's like
well I wouldn't I would just keep I
would just keep living I was like you're
not fun so don't play with Dave listen
I've traveled with you
all over the country I could survive no
chance you can make four days yes zero I
could in the wilderness yes listen I was
in rural Missouri this week and I have
bug bites in places I didn't know
you could not last four days I couldn't
last in the snow so don't put me like in
Alaska
okay at the right temperature put me at
the beach
at the right temperature near a mall you
could do four days are my 16 years old
15 years old
put me near an Amazon fulfillment center
let me have four bars on my cell phone
let me and a mini fridge
and I'm good and a Somalia I think I'm
really
I can do four days we can figure it out
how long would you survive you yeah yeah
he's probably just figured out whenever
you're like damn
36 hours and I'd get sad and then come
back just keep living out there I would
complain a lot but it'd be fine
yeah I think I could do it I can't I
can't do rain there's a couple of here's
the deal I'm officially calling that
bluff we'll talk offline about a dollar
a month I don't want to I know but now
you've put it in the universe I want to
see this is like what yeah and then my
other question for you was when's like
the
questions for conspiracy theory humans
oh we've got a few coming I think you
also do like a really crazy box of
questions oh we've got friendship Enders
if you're with a group of people that
you're like you know it's like asking
about Trump and in covid it's it's like
ways to make sure that nobody ever
invites you back
Hey listen we've got you I love it
I can take people on all
we're gonna have a conspiracy theory
deck we're gonna have one that's just
only about like a really hot topic
religious issues yeah it's gonna be
fantastic I think you should I buy yeah
that's great okay all right to our to
the phones Diana from San Francisco hey
Diana welcome to the show hey
hey thank you thank you for having me
Rachel absolutely how can we help
um I haven't really
um I don't have much savings
and I'm 65. okay I do have I do have a
pension coming to me in about a month
that I need to know should I put it in
my impoto-based 401k
start an IRA or loss it's 208 thousand
dollars it will be the money that I will
actually put down on a house and retire
on
I plan on working five more years
okay
um and you said that this is gonna be
money you're gonna put down for a house
are you looking to to move what your
current living situation I probably
won't stay
and then is Uncle California house it
runs about six hundred thousand so I
think that's a little bit expensive for
home I'll probably move to Arizona and
try to buy something closer to three
hundred thousand okay um I do support a
disabled child I have a 500 000 life
insurance and Trust for her should I
pass on
um I don't essentially have any bills
but uh rent utilities and food
I've been putting
um
six 600 a month into my employer-based
401k which is matched and then um
what's in that account right now
what's in your um what's in your 401
well because I just got this I lost two
jobs during um the covid pricing and
I've only been at this employer for
about eight months now there's five
thousand in there okay okay and Diane do
you have any debt
no no no debt and any savings or just
this pension that's coming to you do you
have anything to your name besides that
401k the 5000.
no okay
okay so Diana what I what I honestly
would suggest you do is is sit down
um with an investment professional
because whenever it comes to this kind
of stuff I just want to make sure that
you have
what you need to save in the next five
years because you said you're going to
be working for five more years
um and with this pension though and
being able to because you're getting it
in a lump sum is that correct right okay
that's correct yeah which is great
because then you can use that for your
advantage but to look to see okay what
is the best way to to save for your age
on taxes to get the
um even the most growth because yes
you're 65 but you still could you know
30 more years more years to live
um so some people would want to put you
in something that is less aggressive but
I mean looking and again a smart
investor Pro or an investment
professional that you trust can sit down
and really map all of this out because
looking to see what's the best again for
your age and how much to live off it
after five years
um to support you and your child ideally
living off that growth of what's coming
and they'll be able to map out all of
that for you
um to really sit down and look at the
details of it but but yeah my knee jerk
is just to make sure that you're putting
it in something that you're going to be
able to live off of that growth once you
once you fully retire completely in five
years of making sure that you do have a
good down payment because I don't want
you going into retirement with a huge
mortgage either so I want you to be able
to weigh all of those options and so
let's just say okay what's the best
what's the best place for my for this
money I also Diana
um Austin are we are we able to do like
a session with a financial coach
go ahead and put her in one
um yes so Diana we're gonna really no
I'm gonna put you in one uh I want you
to hang on the line and we're gonna give
you a free
um with one of our financial coaches
um here's the thing you let you laid out
a few things
that I don't see just eyeballing it the
numbers are gonna work out
being able to go buy a house that's a
three hundred thousand dollar house and
you're gonna pull I don't necessarily
have to buy it but I'd like a large
portion down on it right but if you've
got 208 000 to your name
and you're gonna put down a big chunk of
money towards a house
the mat the math is going to be tough
for you is what I'm saying so I want you
to sit down with one of our coaches and
work through your spending plan over the
next five months and your income plans
to see what you can yeah that's right
um Dan I appreciate your call and hang
on the line here and all your
intentionality
um yep and what you're doing so thank
you so so much all right great hour John
great great hosting with you and thanks
to Kelly James Ben Zach Andrew and
Austin this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]